Hey guys,
You know that I love fishing, right?
With rod and reel, but also
fishing men and women for Christ.
That's why our new merch is out.
It's ready to be ordered.
Fisher of men.
Matthew 4.
This is a reminder for you to not
just go and enjoy life, you know,
your normal hobbies like fishing.
But to go and fish for men and women
to accept Jesus Christ as Lord and
as Savior while they still have time.
So I love fishing and I'm here actually
now and I might go and and see if I can
catch anything here as well so we can enjoy
life, but also remember to look at the people
around you and share the Gospel with them.
This is a great gift that you can buy for
a friend - a father - even for your
woman out there if you love fishing.
But also for the men in your life.
If they love fishing, then you
can get them this t-shirt here as a gift.
As a reminder, that they are a child of God
and they need to be a fisher of men.
Love you guys,
Speak to you soon.
Bye.